right
we now come to the spring statement
i now call the chance of the exchequer
rishi shula
[Applause]
mr speaker
as i stand here men women and children
are huddled in basements across ukraine
seeking protection
soldiers and citizens alike
have taken up arms to defend their land
and families
the sorrow we feel for their suffering
and admiration for their bravery
is only matched by the gratitude we feel
for the security in which we live
and what underpins that security
is the strength of our economy
it gives us the ability to fund the
armed forces we need to maintain our
liberty
the resources we need to support our
allies the power to impose sanctions
which cause severe economic costs and
the flexibility to support businesses
and individuals through crises as they
emerge
but mr speaker
we should be in no doubt
behind putin's invasion is a dangerous
calculation
that democracies are divided politically
weak and economically insecure
incapable of making tough long-term
decisions to strengthen our economies
mr speaker
this calculation is mistaken
what the authoritarian mind perceives as
division
we know are the passionate disagreements
at the heart of our living breathing
democracy
what they see as chaos we know is the
freedom to be dynamic and innovative
and what they call the inherent weakness
of open societies and free economies
we know is the source of our strength
we will confront this challenge to our
values not just in the arms and
resources we send to ukraine
but in strengthening our economy here at
home
so when i talk about security yes i mean
responding to the war in ukraine but i
also mean
the security of a faster growing economy
the security of more resilient public
finances and security for working
families as we help with the cost of
living
mr speaker
today's statement builds a stronger more
secure economy for the united kingdom
we have a moral responsibility to use
our economic strength to support ukraine
and working with international partners
to impose severe costs on putin's regime
we are supplying military aid to help
ukraine defend its borders providing
around 400 million pounds in economic
and humanitarian aid as well as up to
half a billion dollars in multilateral
financial guarantees
and launching the new homes for ukraine
scheme to make sure those forced to flee
have a route to safety here in the uk
and we are imposing sanctions of
unprecedented scale and scope
we've sanctioned over a thousand
individuals entities and subsidiaries
frozen the assets of major russian banks
impose punitive tariffs on t products
restricted russia's access to sterling
clearing to insurance to the uk's
capital market to swift and we've
targeted the russian central bank too
be in no doubt these sanctions
coordinated with our allies are working
the russian ruble plummeted to record
lows the moscow stock exchange has been
largely suspended for a month and the
central bank of russia
has been forced to more than double
interest rates to 20
we warned
that an aggressive
unprovoked invasion would be met with
severe economic costs and it has
i'm proud to say as the whole house will
say
we stand with ukraine
mr speaker
the actions we have taken to sanction
putin's regime are not cost free for us
at home
the invasion of ukraine presents a risk
to our recovery as it does to countries
around the world
we came into this crisis with our
economy growing faster than expected
with the uk having the highest growth
rate in the g7 last year
but the obr has said specifically
there is unusually high uncertainty
around the outlook
it is too early
to know the full impact of the ukraine
war on the uk economy
but their initial view
combined with high global inflation and
continuing supply chain pressures
means the obr now forecast growth this
year of 3.8
the obr then expect the economy to grow
by 1.8
in 2023
and 2.1 1.8 and 1.7
in the following three years
the house will take comfort that the
lower growth outlook has not affected
our strong jobs performance
unemployment is now forecast to be lower
in every year of the forecast
it is already at 3.9 percent back to the
low levels we saw before the pandemic
but mr speaker
the war's most significant impact
domestically is on the cost of living
covid and global factors meant goods and
energy prices were already high
statistics published this morning show
that inflation in february was 6.2
percent
lower than the us and broadly in line
with the euro area
disruptions to global supply chains and
energy markets
combined with the economic response to
putin's aggression
mean the obr expect inflation to rise
further averaging 7.4 percent this year
as i said last month
the government will support the british
people as they deal with the rising
costs of energy
people should know
that we will stand by them as we have
throughout the last two years
that's why we've announced a 9 billion
pound plan to help around 28 million
households pay around half the april
increase in the energy price cap and
people should be reassured that the
energy price cap will protect their
energy bills between now and the autumn
but i want to help people now
so i'm announcing three immediate
measures
first i'm going to help motorists
today
i can announce
for only the second time in 20 years
fuel duty will be cut
[Music]
not by one not even by two but by five
pence per
liter the biggest cut to all fuel duty
rates ever
and while some have called for the cut
to last until august
i have decided it will be in place until
march next year a full 12 months
together with the freeze it's a tax cut
this year for hard-working families and
businesses worth over 5 billion pounds
and it will take effect from 6 p.m
tonight
second
as energy costs rise
we know that energy efficiency
will make a big difference to bills
but if homeowners want to install energy
saving materials at the moment
only some items qualify for a five
percent vat relief and there are complex
rules about who is eligible
the relief used to be more generous
but from 2019 the european court of
justice required us to restrict its
eligibility
but thanks to brexit we're no longer
constrained
by eu law
so i can announce for the next five
years
homeowners having materials like solar
panels heat pumps or insulation
installed will no longer pay five
percent vat they will pay zero
we will also reverse the eu's decision
to take wind and water turbines out of
scope and zero rate them as well
and we will abolish all the red tape
imposed on us by the eu
a family having a solar panel set
installed will see tax savings worth a
thousand pounds and savings on their
energy bill of over 300 pounds per year
and mr speaker
this policy highlights the deficiencies
in the northern ireland protocol
because we won't immediately be able to
apply it to northern ireland
but we will be raising it with the
commission as a matter of urgency and i
want to reassure members from northern
ireland that the executive will receive
a barnet chair of the value of the
relief until it can be introduced uk
wide
and the prime minister will bring
forward further measures to reinforce
our long-term energy security in the
coming weeks
and finally
i want to do more to help our most
vulnerable households with rising costs
they
need targeted support
so i am doubling the household support
fund to a billion pounds with 500
million pounds of new funding
local authorities mr speaker our best
place to help those in need in their
local areas and they will receive this
funding from april
[Music]
mr speaker
we can only afford to provide this extra
support because of our stronger economy
and the tough but responsible decisions
we've taken to rebuild our fiscal
resilience
today's forecast confirm even after the
measures i'm announcing today
we are meeting all our fiscal rules
underlying debt is expected to fall
steadily from 83.5 of gdp in 2022-23
to 79.8
in in 26-27
borrowing as a percentage of gdp
is 5.4 this year 3.9 next year then 1.9
1.3 1.2 and 1.1
in the following years
at a time when the obr have said that
our fiscal headroom
could be wiped out by relatively small
changes to the economic outlook
it is right that the central fiscal
judgment i am making today is to meet
our fiscal rules with a margin of safety
the obr have not accounted for the full
impacts of the war in ukraine
and we should be prepared for the
economy and public finances to worsen
potentially significantly
and the cost of borrowing is continuing
to rise
in the next financial year
we are forecast to spend
83 billion pounds on debt interest the
highest on record
and almost four times the amount we
spent last year
that's why mr speaker
we have already taken difficult
decisions with the public finances and
that's why we will continue to weigh
carefully calls for additional public
spending
more borrowing is not cost or risk-free
i said it last autumn and i say it again
today
borrowing down debt down only the
conservatives can be trusted with
taxpayers money
[Applause]
[Music]
so mr speaker
our response to the immediate crisis in
ukraine has been unwavering
but we must be equally bold in response
to the deeper and more fundamental
challenge putin poses to our values
we must show the world that freedom and
democracy remain the best route to peace
prosperity and happiness
we will do so by strengthening our
economy here at home
to that end
we are helping families with the cost of
living creating the conditions for
accelerated growth and productivity and
making sure the proceeds of growth are
shared fairly
that is not the work of any one
statement but it does begin today and
with one of our most important levers
the tax system
i told the house last autumn my
overarching ambition was to reduce taxes
by the end of this parliament
and we will do so
in a way that is responsible
and sustainable
today
i am publishing a tax plan
we will take
a principled approach to cutting taxes
maintaining space against our fiscal
rules as i have done today
continuing to be disciplined with the
first call on any extra resources being
lower taxes not higher spending
and of course carefully considering the
broader macroeconomic outlook
with those principles in mind
our new tax plan will build a stronger
economy by reducing and reforming taxes
over this parliament in three ways
first we will help families with the
cost of living
second we will create the conditions for
higher growth
and third
we will share the proceeds of growth
fairly ensuring people are left with
more of their own money
let me take each in turn
mr speaker there is now a dedicated
funding source for the country's top
priority the nhs and social care
providing funding over the long term as
demand grows
with every penny going straight to
health and care
if it goes then so does the funding and
that funding is needed now
especially as my right honourable friend
the health secretary's plans to reform
healthcare will ensure every pound of
taxpayers money is well spent when i
said
when i said the conservatives when i
said the conservatives were the party of
public services the party of the nhs i
didn't just mean when it was easy it is
a total commitment
so it is right that the health and care
levy stays but a long-term funding
solution for the nhs and social care is
not incompatible with reducing taxes on
working families
over the last decade
it has been a conservative mission
to promote tax cuts for working people
and simplify the system
that's why that's why conservative-led
governments raised their income tax
personal allowance from six and a half
thousand pounds in 2010 to the new level
of 12
570 pounds
but the equivalent thresholds in
national insurance
which define how much people can earn
nicks free
are still around 3 000 pounds less
now the prime minister pledged in the
2019 election we would increase those
thresholds
we made a big step towards that goal in
my first budget in 2020 increasing the
national insurance threshold to 9
500 pounds
today we take the next step
our current plan
is to increase the next threshold this
year
by 300 pounds
but i'm not going to do that mr speaker
i'm going to increase it by the full 3
000 pounds
delivering our promise to fully equalize
the nips and income tax thresholds
and not incrementally over many years
but in one go this year
from this july people will be able to
earn 12
570 pounds a year without paying a
single
on penny insurance
that is a 6 billion personal tax cut for
30 million people across the united
kingdom
a tax cut for employees worth over
330 pounds a year
the largest increase in a basic rate
threshold ever
and this largest single personal tax cut
in a decade
[Applause]
[Music]
the institute the institute for fiscal
studies has called it the best way to
help low and middle earners through the
tax system it creates what the center
for policy studies has called a
universal working income it is a tax cut
that rewards work
and mr speaker
mr speaker
around 70
of all workers
will have their taxes cut by more than
the amount they'll pay through the new
levy
once again showing it is this
conservative government delivering for
hard-working families and helping with
the cost of living
[Applause]
so mr speaker
the first part of our tax plan for a
stronger economy is to support families
with the cost of living
but as i set out in last month's maze
lecture to lift our growth and
productivity we need the private sector
to train more invest more and innovate
more people capital ideas that's how
we'll create a new culture of enterprise
the second part of our tax plan
the plan sets out tax cutting options on
business investment and innovation with
final decisions to be announced in the
autumn budget but these are significant
and complex questions so we will work
with businesses over the summer to get
the answers right let me explain to the
house the direction of travel
first people
we lag international peers and adult
technical skills just 18 of 25 to 64
year olds hold vocational qualifications
a third lower than the oecd average and
uk employers spend just half the
european average on training their
employees
so we will consider whether the current
tax system include including the
operation of the apprenticeship levy is
doing enough to incentivize businesses
to invest in the right kinds of training
second ideas
over the last 50 years innovation drove
around half the uk's productivity growth
but since the financial crisis the rate
of increase has slowed more than in
other countries and our lower rate of
innovation explains almost all our
productivity gap with the united states
right now right now we know that the
amount businesses spend on r d as a
percentage of gdp
is less than half the oecd average
and that is despite us spending more on
tax relief than almost every other
country
something is not working
so we'll reform r d tax credits so that
they're effective and better value for
money we'll expand the generosity of the
release to include data cloud computing
and pure maths and we'll consider in the
autumn whether to make the r d
expenditure credit more generous
third capital
weak private sector investment is a long
standing cause of our productivity gap
internationally
capital investment by uk businesses is
considerably lower than the oecd average
of 14
and it accounts for fully half our
productivity gap with france and germany
once the super deduction ends next year
our overall tax treatment for capital
investment will be far less generous
than other advanced economies
we're going to fix that in the autumn
budget
we will cut the tax rates on business
investment and i look forward to
discussing the best ways to do that with
businesses
people capital ideas three priorities
for business tax cuts this autumn
but mr speaker
i want to help smaller businesses right
now
so let me remind the house of our plan
our business rates discount will take
effect in april for retail hospitality
and leisure businesses they will get a
50
discount on their business rates bill up
to 110 000 pounds a typical pub will
save 5 000 pounds that's a tax cut for
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses worth 1.7 billion pounds
taking effect in just a week's time
our help to grow management scheme
offers businesses many mbas 90 funded by
government a benefit worth several
thousand pounds help to grow digital
gives businesses a fifty percent
discount on buying new software up to
five thousand pounds we've also
increased the annual investment
allowance to a million pounds so that
small and medium-sized businesses will
feel the benefit of full expensing
but mr speaker i want to respond to the
specific calls from small businesses
with one further announcement today
the employment allowance cuts small
businesses tax bills making it cheaper
to employ workers
in my first budget two years ago i
increased that allowance today i'm going
further from april the employment
allowance will increase to 5 000 pounds
that's a new tax cut worth up to a
thousand pounds for half a million small
businesses starting in just two weeks
time
so mr speaker future tax cuts on
business investment and innovation a
business rates discount worth 1.7
billion pounds help to grow schemes
worth thousands of pounds per business
an annual investment allowance worth up
to a million pounds and a new tax cut on
the cost of employment worth a thousand
pounds per company once again mr speaker
it is this conservative government
delivering for british business
mr speaker
the tax plan i've announced today
will help people and businesses deal
with rising costs
will help raise the future growth rate
of this country
but we want the proceeds of growth
shared fairly the third objective of our
tax plan
the knowledge you can keep more of what
you earn is a powerful incentive for
people to work hard
it means greater economic security and
we know that individuals spend their
money better than governments do
we've already we've already announced
today the equalization of personal tax
thresholds giving over 30 million
workers a tax cut worth over 330 pounds
and over time
i want to go further
but tax cuts must be paid for they must
be prioritized and they must fit the
economic circumstances of the time
a clear goal for conservative
chancellors and even some labour ones
has been to cut income tax
the fact this has happened only twice in
20 years tells you how hard it is to do
kovid and the war in ukraine have only
added to the difficulty of achieving
this by the end of this parliament i'm
sure all members of this house recognize
and understand those challenges
it would clearly be irresponsible to
meet this ambition this year
and yet i refuse to let that ambition
wither and drift
by 2024 the obr currently expect
inflation to be back under control
debt falling sustainably and the economy
growing
our fiscal rules are met with a clear
margin of safety
and so my final announcement today
is this
i can confirm
before the end of this parliament in
2024 for the first time in 16 years
the basic rate of income tax will be cut
from 20 to 19 pence in the pound
a tax cut for workers for pensioners for
savers a 5 billion pound tax cut for 30
million people and let me be clear with
the house it is fully costed and fully
paid for in the plans announced today
last year i told the house i would cut
taxes for hard-working families but i
would do so in a responsible and
sustainable way
and today
i am delivering on that promise
so let me say this
cutting taxes is not easy it requires
hard work
prioritization and the willingness to
make difficult and often unpopular
arguments elsewhere
it is only because this government has
been prepared to make those difficult
but responsible choices to fix our
public finances
that i can stand here and tell this
house that not only
are taxes being cut but the debt is also
falling whilst public spending is
increasing
this doesn't happen by accident mr
speaker we can deliver for the british
people today and into the future because
unlike the party opposite we have a plan
a plan
a plan that reforms and improves public
services
a plan to grow our economy a plan to
level up across the united kingdom a
plan that helps families with the cost
of living and yes a tax plan
that cuts taxes on working families by
over 330 pounds
cuts taxes on fuel by five pence they
liter
cuts taxes on business and yes for the
first time in a long time cuts income
tax
mr speaker let me end let me end by
simply saying this my tax plan delivers
the biggest net cut to personal taxes is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and quite rightly the house heard the
chancellor i have no wants to show the
same respect
to the shadow chance of the ex-checker
thank you mr speaker
today was the day that the chancellor
could have put a windfall tax on oil and
gas producers to provide
real help to families
but he didn't
today was the day the chancellor could
have set out a proper plan to support
businesses and create good jobs
but he didn't yeah today was a day that
he could have properly scrapped his
national insurance hike
he didn't
we said it was the wrong tax at the
wrong time
the wrong choice
today the chancellor has finally
admitted he got that one wrong yeah
inflation is at its highest level for 30
years and rising
energy prices at record highs
people are worried sick
for all his words
it is clear that the chancellor does not
understand the scale of the challenge
exactly he talks about providing
security for working families
but his choices are making the cost of
living crisis worse
not better
mr speaker
this situation following putin's
criminal assault on ukraine remains
gravely serious
just one month after the invasion so
much has changed with repercussions for
years to come
but the chancellor has failed today
to explain why he chose to sign off on a
reduction in our country's armed forces
last october
will the chancellor confirm
if the government's target army size is
still being reduced by 10 000 troops
and let me say this to the chancellor
labour will support whatever is needed
on defense and security to keep our
country safe
[Applause]
mr speaker
the tremors following putin's aggression
will impact on britain
including economically
but the cost of living crisis predates
putin's attack on ukraine
in october inflation was already
forecast to be double the bank of
england's target
and yet the prime minister said
that fears of inflation were unfounded
today we learned that inflation has
reached 6.2 percent and is expected to
go higher in the coming months
people are rightly looking to their
government to help them weather this
storm
labor will support sensible measures to
ease this pressure
but what the chancellor has announced
today
says everything we need to know about
his priorities
the cost of living crisis
is heating hitting people particularly
hard
because incomes have been squeezed
during the last 12 years of conservative
governments
ordinary families
disabled people
pensioners
facing really difficult choices
moms skipping meals so their children
don't
families struggling to buy new school
shoes and uniforms for their children
older people hesitating to put their
heating on because they're worried about
the cost
at the weekend the chancellor was asked
about fuel poverty and he didn't even
know the numbers
it is shameful that he doesn't
because when martin lewis predicts that
10 million people could be pushed into
fuel poverty the chancellor should sit
up and listen
and we know that pensions and security
are not going to keep up with inflation
pensioners and those on social security
will be getting a real terms cut in
their incomes cutting the pensions so
what analysis has the chancellor done on
the impact of benefits being uprated by
less than inflation
how many more children and pensioners
will drift into poverty because of the
choices of this government
cutting the pension and who does the
chancellor prioritize
he continues to defend the record
profits of oil and gas producers
who themselves admit that they have more
money than they know what to do with
bp describes this crisis as a cash
machine for them
but it is british people who are paying
out
and it is deeply regrettable that the
snp have joined the tories in wanting to
shield oil and gas producers from
labour's progressive measures
when i
when i set out
when i set out
when i set out labour's plans for a
windfall tax in january
we estimated that it would have raised
1.2 billion pounds
now because of the continued rise in
global oil and gas prices
it would today raise over 3 billion
pounds
that's money that could be used
to help families and pensioners and
businesses
with a cut to vat a real brexit dividend
that would help working families and
pensioners across our country
and a targeted warm homes discount that
would see
families and pensioners on the lowest
and modest incomes being supported by
600 pounds
now that today the chancellor comes
along
after 12 years of failure on energy
efficiency and announces a va t cut on
building materials this is wholly
inadequate
a proper energy efficiency scheme like
the one we have set out could cut bills
by 400 pounds to people from next year
and the silence from the chancellor
on our energy intensive manufacturing
industries is appalling
at this time of national crisis people
and businesses need a government that is
on their side
now the chancellor spoke of difficult
choices
and i agree
there are always choices to be made
like hoot attacks and huta shields
despite the chancellor's reluctant
measures
the facts are that he is still taking
money out of people's purses and wallets
with an increase in national insurance
contributions
the changes that he is making today
begs the question
why did he embark on these changes in
the first place despite the warnings
from the labour party and from many many
others
now it's one thing for the prime
minister and chancellor to disagree with
each other
but the centerpiece of the statement
that the chancellor has delivered today
is based on a disagreement with himself
[Music]
and for all his tax rising
on millions in the middle where is the
increased tax contribution for the very
wealthiest in society
a landlord with a large number of
properties won't be paying a penny more
in taxes
but their tenants will
someone with significant income from
buying and selling stocks and shares
won't be paying any more in tax
but those people powering our economy
will the chancellor has made the wrong
choices
now the chancellor says we can't help
everyone
and that's absolutely true
but who has the chancellor been helping
out
those who have been swindling the
taxpayer
the chancellor left open the vaults
for widespread waste
crony contracts and a frenzy of fraud
it was as his former tory treasury
minister put it
happy days if you are a crook
7 billion items of ppe not usable and
now being burnt
tax payers money literally going up in
smoke
three and a half billion pounds worth of
contracts awarded to friends donors and
pub landlords
and it gets worse
the chancellor has been signing checks
to fraudsters including organized
criminals and drug dealers
let's put the chancellor's fraud failure
in context
he has lost a staggering
11.8 billion pounds of public money to
fraud
this is twice the amount that a previous
conservative government lost on black
wednesday
as a result of let's face it this
jaw-dropping incompetence the
conservatives have been funding crime
instead of fighting it
and now the chancellor has the audacity
to come to british taxpayers
asking them to pay more to fill his
black holes
but there can be no cover-up to hide
political embarrassment let's call in
the national crime agency to investigate
we need answers people held to accounts
because let's be clear
taxpayers want their money back
the truth is mr speaker people can no
longer afford the conservatives
working families can't
pensioners can't
and businesses can't
the weak growth forecast we've seen
today
should be flashing red on the
chancellor's desk
and the chancellor says in his statement
today that the work starts today
is he serious the conservatives have
been in government now for 12 years
what 12 hours
what has taken them so
long because
since his party entered government the
uk has experienced the biggest downgrade
in growth of any major economy
with the last labour government economic
growth was 2.1 a year
under the last 12 years of the
conservatives it's averaged 1.5
and now we know that growth has been
downgraded this year too
now growth is essential
for funding our public services
keeping taxes under control
and keeping a handle on public finances
too
that's why labour have announced a tough
set of fiscal rules to get our debts and
our deficit down
but the truth is that because of this
government's failure to get the economy
growing
it's this chancellor that has to put up
taxes on families and businesses are
staggering 15 times
this chancellor
has raised taxes more in the last two
years than any previous chancellor in
the last 50.
now he says it's all down to the
pandemic but the truth is the
conservatives have become the party of
high taxation because they are the party
of low growth
[Applause]
now i understand that the chancellor has
a portrait of nigel lawson above his
desk
well
today we've got an energy price crisis
record prices at the pumps inflation is
back
the truth is
he's not nigel lawson mr speaker
he's ted heath
with an instagram account
labor would be getting the economy
firing on all cylinders
ensuring that we buy make and sell more
in britain scrapping business rates and
replacing them with a fairer system fit
for the 21st century something that
small businesses and high street
businesses are crying out for and the
chancellor mentioned it not at all in
his statement today
a climate investment pledge to
decarbonize the economy create good jobs
in every part of britain and strengthen
our energy security too
businesses are seeing unprecedented
increases in their costs right now
but all we hear from this chancellor
today is a promise of jam tomorrow
rather than the support that is needed
now
and today's statement
lacks the long-term plan for
productivity skills and growth where is
it chancellor
mr speaker
i can't help but feel
that in both the chancellor's recent
maze lecture
and in his statement today
we are presented with increasingly
incredible claims
perhaps the chancellor has been taking
inspiration from the characters in alice
in wonderland
or should i say alice in sunak land
because nothing here
is quite as it seems either
it's the sort of place where a
chancellor celebrates giving people 200
pounds
to help them with their spiraling energy
bills before explaining that he needs it
all back
exactly in sunaklan the chancellor
proclaims i believe in lower taxes while
at the same time as hiking alice's
national insurance contributions
so alice asks the chancellor
when did lower taxes
mean higher taxes
has down really become the new up yeah
the chancellor follows humpty dumpty's
advice and says
when i use the word it means just what i
choose it to me neither more
nor less
now alice knows that under the
conservatives taxes
are at their highest level
in decades as a result of the policies
of this very same child
in fact
this chancellor was the only g7 finance
minister to raise taxes on working
people during this crucial year of
recovery
[Music]
curiouser and curiouser
as alice climbs out of the rabbit hole
to leave sunak land she recalls the
words of the white rabbit and concludes
that perhaps the chancellor's reality is
just different from yours
the actual reality mr speaker
is that this chancellor's failure to
back a win for tax and his stubborn
desire to pursue a national insurance
tax rise are the wrong choices
in eight days time people's energy bills
will be rising by 54
two weeks today the chancellor's latest
tax hike will start hitting working
people and their employers
his national insurance tax rise was a
bad idea last september and he's
admitted it's an even worse one today
the chancellor is making an historic
mistake
today was a day to scrap the tax rise on
jobs today was the day to bring forward
a windfall tax today was the day for the
chancellor to set out a plan to support
british businesses
but on the basis of the statement today
and the misguided choices of this
chancellor
families and businesses will from now on
endure significant hardship as a result
the chancellor has failed to appreciate
the scaling scale of the challenge that
we face
and yet again he is making the wrong
choices for our country
[Applause]
well
mr speaker i'd like to i'd like to thank
the honourable lady for her reply and
she raised the number of points which
i'll of course come into in due course
but i must say listening to her
statement it did sound as if covid and
the huge damage that it had done to our
economy and public finances had never
actually happened
it sounded as if we didn't need to do
things like furlough or support
businesses and provide emergency funding
to schools the councils and yes the nhs
because whilst her party supported all
of those policies at the time they now
seem unwilling to pay for them
and there is a pattern there mr speaker
they're always happy to spend taxpayers
money just not take care of it
let me mr speaker just briefly address
some of the specific points that the
honourable lady uh mentioned i thought
it's telling that she opened her
statement uh yet again calling for a
windfall tax we know on this side of the
house mr speaker we want to encourage
more investment in the north sea we want
more domestic energy we want more jobs
for the uk and a windfall tax would put
that off which is why within prime
minister will be bringing forward a
comprehensive energy security strategy
in the coming weeks to address that uh
she talked about business rates and
supporting businesses mr speaker
in just uh just a week's time uh small
businesses will be getting a 50 discount
on their business rates bill in the
retail hospitality and leisure sector
that's the biggest tax cut to business
rates outside of coronavirus since the
business rate system was created
1.7 billion pounds and i know she's said
that she would like to abolish business
rates she also says she has some fiscal
rules i haven't quite figured out where
she's going to pay for the 25 billion
pounds uh of tax cuts that that involves
but i look forward to hearing it she
talked about defense spending mr speaker
i must say here i mean it's all very
well to talk about the size of the army
at least at least the party opposite now
seems to think that we should actually
have an on
which is a welcome conversion uh mr
speaker
this week
it was because
because it was because how seriously we
take this nation's security mr speaker
that in 2020 when we decided to do just
short-term spending settlements for most
departments there was one department we
singled out for special treatment one
department that got a four-year
settlement in advance of everyone else
and that was the ministry of defense mr
speaker and in that settlement they
received 24 billion pounds of new cash
the largest uplift of defence spending
since the end of the cold war ensuring
that we are not just the second largest
spender in europe in nato but the fifth
largest in the world a record that we on
this side of the house are very proud of
she talked also mr speaker about
pensions again thanks to the actions of
this government since 2010 because of
their governments
we put in place the triple lock not
something that the party of the opposite
ever did when they were in power it
means that pensions are now 2
300 pounds higher than they were in 2010
and 700 pounds more than if the triple
lock hadn't been in existence during
that time and i'm pleased to say mr
speaker that the state pension now
relative to earnings is at the highest
level it has been in over 30 years
this party will always be on the side of
pensioners mr speaker and then and then
just briefly to turn to her comments on
tax and i'm not sure perhaps if she and
fair enough it's a short time to respond
mr speaker if she fully understood the
implications of the tax cut that was
announced today
the increase in national insurance
thresholds to fully equalize them is a
six billion pound tax cut for 30 million
uk workers
it is the largest increase in thresholds
ever the biggest personal tax cut in a
decade and it is worth 330 pounds for
those workers mr stika and it means and
it means and this is the part that i
don't know if she's realized because
she's talking about the levy and making
sure that we direct our policy of those
who need our help there's a reason the
institute independent institute for
fiscal studies called this the best way
to help low and middle earners through
the tax system and that is because that
is because
70
of workers will pay less tax even
accounting for the levy mr speaker it is
more generous than the policy she is
advocating and combined with the other
tax cuts we've announced today mr
speaker as i said this plan represents
the biggest cut the biggest net cut to
personal taxes in a quarter of a century
mr speaker
i let me let me conclude by by saying
this the plan that we've announced today
as i said has only been possible because
we have taken tough decisions with the
public finances and not necessarily
always popular
but always responsible and always honest
it is two years to the day mr speaker
that the country first entered lockdown
and suffered the biggest economic shock
in over 300 years
an unprecedented collective national
effort was undertaken
and two years later
this government hasn't only fixed the
public finances but people are back in
jobs debt is falling and taxes are now
being cut now no government gets every
call right we learn from our mistakes we
strive to improve
but even if they won't admit it mr
speaker members opposite will recognize
this day as an achievement which we all
can celebrate i've said it before to the
party opposite and i'll say it again
there is a fine line between reasonable
criticism and political opportunism and
in my experience the british people can
always tell the difference
i think the shadow chancellor's remarks
we best remembered when she pointed out
the conservatives won the 2010 election
and we won the 2019 election it's
probably a very good thing for the
country that we did
chancellor has met the major obligations
which have public spending which helps
the economy to grow which allows for
more jobs and more government revenue
coming in and he's also concentrating
he's pointed out just now that the
changes to national insurance do the
things that martin lewis would applaud
as well as the institutes and you have
those three people supporting so my
support for me so it's very welcome
can i point out to him ask him
to remember
that pensioners don't just have the
state pension many have fixed pensions
on top and getting inflation down as
fast as possible is vitally important to
them they can't go for a bigger pay
increase if they're not at work
and can i finally say to him
that some areas of public spending don't
make it easy to have efficiencies
if teachers salaries make up most of the
cost of education
it's very important to make sure that we
don't squeeze education and wreck
the schools and the future of the pupils
on things like cladding
when amendments come to the building
safety bill from the lord can you please
not keep his purse completely shut but
if money needs advancing so the people's
homes can be safe and saleable please
consider that openly
mr speaker i thank my honorable friend
for his support and i think he's uh i
think he's right to highlight some of
the independent commentators who
supported the policies announced today
i'll just touch on one of the things he
said which is about education spending i
agree with him it's vital for our
country's future that we support our
teachers and support our children that's
why the prime minister announced in
total five billion pounds of catch-up
funding to help those children with the
learning recover the learning that they
lost during the pandemic also why we're
raising per pupil cash amounts by 1500
pounds over this parliament and raising
teachers starting salaries to 30 000
pounds as our manifesto committed to
now comes the snp spokesperson alison
tulas
thank you very much mr speaker well mr
speaker this this tax plan that the
chancellor announced it's very thin it
is lightweight and it's superficial and
it's exactly what we've come to expect
from this chancellor
because what we heard today from the
chancellor was not enough it was utterly
detached from the needs of our
constituents up and down these islands
this has been a cost of living crisis
over a decade in the making layer upon
layer austerity which stripped back
public services and punished people
through brutal social security cuts
brexit which is driven away skilled
workers and increased costs for
businesses and for individuals
covid where we saw public money splurged
in its billions on crony contracts while
some people were entirely excluded from
support and now those who got support
under cease are expected to pay tax on
it just to add insult to injury
and now home energy costs which are
already soaring before the increase in
hostilities in ukraine are forcing
households to the brink
inflation running at 6.2 percent it's
highest in 30 years hitting the poorest
hardest
food prices rising especially for the
basics and food banks seeing record
numbers of people coming through their
doors the chancellor said he's going to
increase the household support fund
brotherly is that it is that it because
people are desperate and they need a
good deal more help than that
mr speaker we know that sanctioning
russia is not cost free but the tories
cannot use this as a sleight of hand to
distract from the layers of pain which
lie beneath the current crisis
each of these layers has seen political
choices and opportunities for change
squandered by this uk tory government
and its predecessors and we see this
again today and this chancellor has
increased taxes more than two years than
gordon brown did in 10 while people are
struggling
the treasury select committee issued a
report this morning and it says that the
uk government must take further action
to support uk households in particular
those on lower incomes to management
manage the subsequent rise in energy
and other costs
now his announcement on nix is welcome
we've been calling for it for years it's
not something that the chancellor should
have brought today it's something he
should have brought a long time ago and
hiking national insurance is a tax on
individuals but also mr speaker attacks
on jobs
employers are already facing increased
costs in energy and materials and this
is a pressure that many businesses will
not be able to bear
smes in particular need more support
hospitality and tourism in particular
have struggled through the pandemic and
now the chancellor is moving vat from 12
and a half percent back to 20 at a time
when consumers have much less money in
their pockets we in these benches called
for this cut cuts before the chancellor
brought it in and we support the uk
hospitalities that's enough campaign
mr speaker cutting universal credit by
20 pounds a week at a time when people
need it the most
carly a single mum spoke at the
gingerbread reception on monday and told
us all how important it was that that
money was there because things are
tighter than they have ever been
no further support for people and legacy
benefits and disabled people who often
face higher energy costs and have no
option
in those costs
a taper put in place that only helps
people that are in work
benefits just not going far enough as
they don't take place with inflation and
a welfare cap that punishes people for
their circumstances
and a caught and an end to the triple
lock and nothing for the waspy women
outside campaignings yet today it's
still losing out and what should have
rightfully been theirs
the scottish government by contrast is
doing what it can within its limited
budget to support people upgrading the
eight scottish security social security
benefits that we control by six percent
increasing the scottish child payment to
20 pounds a week a lifeline to families
this government should be doing the same
if i feel is something but it doesn't
help those who are paying for trains and
buses the chancellor cut air passenger
duty during cop26 but he still offers
nothing for the millions of commuters
who use public transport every day
mr speaker i don't know if the
chancellor has ever had a prepayment
meter i don't think they fixed them i
don't think they fit them mr speaker for
swimming pools
the four and a half million people
across these islands she says it's
pathetic four and a half million people
across these islands
[Music]
four and a half million people across
these islands experiencing the stress
and despair of watching the money run
out on their pre-payment meters
prepayment customers mr speaker already
pay higher bills than those in direct
debit and they may struggle even to
access the chancellor's heat now pay
later loan if it doesn't go
automatically to pay back the debts on
that meter mr speaker the fuel bank
foundation who provide top-ups to those
who are struggling on pre-payment meters
have seen a 75
increase in demand already that's before
the prices we are seeing now
nothing either from the chancellor on
customers on heating oil on or lpg who
must fill up by the tank and heat those
on heating oil have seen their tank
costs
for 500 litres at a time go from 250
pounds to between 600 and 900 pounds
these people have no choice about how
they get that energy where are they in
the chancellor's priorities today
mr speaker nuclear which the government
touted an awful lot before the the
statement today and was missing from the
chancellor's statement interestingly is
not the answer to reducing people's
bills it is slow and it is
eye-wateringly expensive we know already
from the nuclear financing bill that
what the government already proposes
will add 63 billion pounds to people's
energy bills
63 billion pounds mr speaker
the government should instead be fixing
the long-standing inequality of grant
charging investing more in onshore and
offshore wind in tidal and in solar and
bringing carbon capture and storage in
the northeast of scotland off their
reserve bench now make it a real net
zero transition worthy of the name
they could invest in a national
programme of heat pumps retrofitting and
insulating and i was glad to see his
announcement on home energy efficiency
and repairs because this is something
we've called on for a very long time mr
speaker but this paltry announcement
does not go nearly far enough not even
meeting the significant home energy
intervention scotland is already making
mr speaker this chancellor has choices
he could have looked at windfall tax and
profits yes to the title chancellor oil
and gas but also amazon circle netflix
why should they not have to pay their
mega profits during the pandemic
and the chancellor has had a windfall of
his own tax revenues are higher than
expected the deficit is 30 billion lower
than planned and looking at the obr
reports that came out today
vat has gone up by
21.7 billion 21.7 billion extra and the
chancellor's coffee coffers
and self uh self assessment up by 5.2
billion pounds then forecast late last
year
this could have been used to cushion the
cost of living crisis and to invest in
renewables into winners of fossil fuel
money-saving expert martin lewis was
starking his warning in sunday morning
he says as the money-saving expert has
been known for this i'm virtually out of
tools to help people now and he said
while watching this that his head sunk
there is no help for people on energy
mr speaker in closing people face a
chance a crisis that the chancellor
could have done more to avert and he's
made the choice in so many ways not to
act there's nothing in his announcement
today for scotland and we in these
ventures look forward to the day when
scotland has a government with the full
fiscal powers to make sure that all of
our people all of them can have a decent
standard of living and that no child
goes to bed with an empty tummy and a
cold home
church with the ex jacker
well uh mr speaker the honourable lady
said there's nothing in this statement
for scotland maybe she missed the part
about the uk wide fuel duty cut which
will save a typical
together with the freeze will save a
typical driver 100 pounds this year
typical van driver 200 pounds maybe she
missed the part about the largest
increase the personal tax thresholds
ever a six billion pound tax cut which
will help 2.4 million people in scotland
starting in just a few months time
or indeed the 75 000 businesses that
benefit from the employment allowance
again a thousand pound tax cut for
scottish businesses coming in very
shortly and actually what i didn't hear
from her uh mr speaker she mentioned
that scotland wants uh as ever more
fiscal autonomy scotland already does
have a considerable degree of fiscal
autonomy and what i didn't hear was
whether the snp
are going to deliver the same income tax
cut for scottish taxpayers that the uk
government is delivering as paid for in
these numbers in 2024 i look forward to
hearing from the honourable lady that
the scottish government will be cutting
taxes for their taxpayers with the
powers and funding that they will get uh
mr speaker i i always i always want to
make sure that we look after the most
vulnerable in our society the honorable
lady mentioned a single mother who she
knew i'm pleased and proud in fact that
because of the actions of this
government increasing the national
living wage in april by 6.6 percent by
cutting the uc taper rate uh mr speaker
and indeed by the increase in personal
thresholds today taken all together all
tax and welfare changes that single
mother of two children working full-time
on the national living wage will now be
one thousand six hundred pounds better
off
mr speaker and then the last point i
think the uh honorable lady was talking
about was um
was on businesses and and again i'd say
to her we are providing a business rate
discount for businesses and scotland of
course has received the barnet share of
that money business rate discount here
coming in for retail hospitality and
leisure businesses in just a few weeks
and i know the scottish government will
have the resources to do the same thing
and then lastly on prepayment meetings
where the honourable lady made a comment
i'm acutely aware that millions of
families rely on prepayment meetings
which is why when we designed the energy
support package that we announced in
fenrir we had particular care to those
people to make sure that they would
receive the same benefit and indeed we
found out and we made sure that 40 of
them will automatically get the 200
pounds rebate in october and for the
remainder
mr speaker we are working with baze and
the industry to ensure that all of those
people get the same benefit as well they
will either receive a voucher a check in
the post or indeed something called a
special access message to their phone on
sms so that when they go to one of the
retailers that they use to top up their
meter they will also benefit from the
actions that we have taken because this
conservative government is on the side
of everyone mr speaker
chair of the slag committee mel stride
thank you uh thank you mr speaker and
can i broadly welcome my right
honourable friends uh statement the
devil of course will always be in the
detail and we look forward to seeing him
before the treasury select committee
next week along with the obr and various
economists including the ifs to which my
right honourable friend
has eluded
i welcome the cut to fuel duty it will
help both motorists
and consumers will be important for
businesses as well the vat reduction
around energy efficiency and solar i
think is very important in terms of the
context of the sanctions on russia at
the moment and the importance of energy
self-sufficiency where we can achieve it
the hardship fund will be a very
targeted measure uh as well which i
think is important and i know that small
businesses will be delighted to have
heard about the increase in the
employment allowance to five thousand
pounds which is a key ask for the
federation of small
businesses um i along with many others
in this house would like to have seen
the national uh um the ni uh increases
uh for next year to have been strapped
in their entirety but i have to say that
uh the increase in the threshold that my
writable friend uh has announced today
has been very significant indeed and far
more significant than i imagined that it
would be the big question that my right
and boyfriend of course will be asked
will be within the context of the fiscal
targets that i think we're all agreed we
need to meet has he used enough of that
headroom now as opposed to having it as
a hedge against the uncertainties of the
future to which he eluded and which are
very real around inflation and interest
rates and the effect of that on the cost
of borrowing uh to the government so i
just wonder whether i could ask him to
speak a little bit more
about his fiscal headroom he will have
had the advantage of seeing the obr
figures which i have not and what his
assessment is of that particularly
around the deficit target
secondly madam deputy speaker on the
issue of growth when my right honourable
friend has pointed out the obr
downgrades which are not surprising in a
high inflation environment and the
effect that that will have on consumer
demand the dampening effect i was very
pleased that he referenced his maze
lecture because it is going to be
essential that we now focus on
innovation on people and driving up
capital investment
my right honourable friend made
reference i think to a consultation
around how to improve capital investment
where we do currently lag behind our
competitors in the g7 and i wonder if he
could tell us a little bit more about
the timeline for that consultation and
when he expects to be able to provide
important certainty for businesses in
that respect
thank you madam deputy speaker i thank
my honourable friend for his words of
support just to briefly address his two
substantive questions the tax plan
published today in the spring statement
document has a range of options for how
one could cut taxes on investment i look
forward to having that conversation with
him colleagues and the business
community
about the right way to achieve the
outcome we want with final decisions to
be announced in the autumn budget to
take effect in spring 2023 after the
super deduction ends i won't get into
the detail of them now uh with regard to
headroom we have about one percent of
gdp headroom against both the stock and
the flow rule so both the debt falling
and the borrowing rule uh on the
borrowing side that's about in line with
previous chancellors on the stock rule
it's a bit less uh the average over the
last decade has been about 1.7
but what i would say to him is the
headroom includes the tax cut in 2024 so
that has been fully paid for and costed
in these numbers so i do believe we're
taking a responsible and pragmatic
approach but he's right to point out the
risk the obr have said that relatively
small changes in the macroeconomic
outlook could wipe out the entire
headroom which is why it's right we
continue to be disciplined on public
spending
or i would like to
try to get everybody in um that means uh
asking one question um
not making short statements but just
asking one question so the chancellor
can answer one back dame meg hilliard
thank you madam deputy speaker earlier
in prime minister's questions the prime
minister batted off a question about
fraud uh during covid uh by suggesting
that it was just about delivering but it
was the chancellor madam deputy speaker
that's wrote out the book gave the
ministerial direction for the
bounce-back loans to be paid at such
speed that even without even with a
48-hour longer check they might have
avoided the duplicate fraudulent claims
that weren't stopped until a month later
that 4.7 billion on fraud would have
mitigated some of the measures for
example the national insurance increase
does he now regret that he didn't pause
for thought and be more cautious on
fraud
madam deputy speak i've got a lot of
respect for the honorable lady but on
this matter i do believe she's wrong and
it's with incredible hindsight to now
point out issues that at the time she
and nor did anybody else raise and in
fact the opposite i was here on a daily
basis being told not to get money out in
weeks or months but to get money out in
hours and days
to put longer for checks in place would
have taken weeks madam deputy speaker so
i do stand by the decision that we made
we have put various safeguards in place
we have blocked two billion pounds of
bounce back loans sixty thousand because
of the checks at companies house the
national intelligence service and nca
are now in the process of succeed
they're successfully prosecuting dozens
of people we're striking people off from
companies house and we're investing more
today in the ncaa mattis and the british
business bank so they can work on the
interventions that we know are doing
very well but i do think it is wrong to
pretend now that they wanted to do
something at the time which they didn't
greg clark thank you very much
madam deputy speaker can i congratulate
the chancellor on a tax cutting
deficit cutting tax simplifying
statement which is very much in the
traditions of nigel lawson
he mentions research and development tax
credits
and we have a target to get to 2.4
percent of investment in r d across the
economy by 2027.
are we on track for that and when will
the changes to r d tax credits come into
effect so that it can increase progress
further on that
my honourable friend for his support and
i know this is an area that he has
particular interest and concern for you
know on the government side that 2.4 is
comprised of two things about a deputy
speaker is what the government spends
but also what private businesses spend i
can reassure him we are more than on
track uh for the government bit of that
we already spend the oecd average on the
2.4 and that will go up over the course
of this parliament by 50
so the government is doing its bit as i
said in the statement in the maze
lecture the private sector lag
significantly internationally in terms
of how much it spends the changes we
make to r d will all come into effect
in spring next year announced finally in
the autumn budget i look forward to
working with him his committee and
others and he wrote a forward for a very
helpful report on this topic so that we
get these changes right and drive up
private sector investment in r d cli
pets thank you my dr speaker the
sheffield star today there is two
stories um sheffield is still a city of
steel we have ben mciver the president
of forge solutions group a company which
employs 400 skilled workers in the steel
industry
begging for help with the rising energy
costs as they simply can't pass these
costs onto their customers we have
workers at liberty steel protesting
about the broken promise from the prime
minister that if we left the eu he would
cut energy bills for steel companies
why is the chancellor chosen to break
the prime minister's promise
well no madam deputy speaker we've
provided over two billion pounds worth
of support for energy intensive
industries over the past several years
including i believe over 600 million
pounds for the steel industry that comes
in a variety of ways whether it's free
allowances or compensation on some of
the ets and other carbon price
mechanisms we also in the spending
review announced hundreds of millions of
pounds to support industry to make the
transition to using cleaner energy
spending a review the chancellor gave a
lifeline to maintain nursery schools by
confirming supplementary funding but not
all schools qualify for that funding so
can i appeal to him to work with the
education secretary to identify the
modest amount of additional funding
needed to put all maintained nursery
schools on a stable financial footing
for the future
well my my honourable friend has
championed this issue consistently uh
since i've had this job and she deserves
enormous credit for that i'd be very
happy to talk to her and take up her
proposals with the department for
education as well
sammy wilson thank you modern liberty
speaker it'd be church not to accept
that the chancellor has sought to deal
with many of the issues which face
living working families today but i
believe that given the windfall and
taxes which he has experienced that
there could have been more done to help
with fuel costs energy bills and other
cost of living increases significant
that the chancellor cannot apply all of
his taxes to northern ireland because of
non-iron protocol shows it need to be
dealt with but
chancellor you started off your st the
chancellor started off a statement today
referring to ukraine and yet
surprisingly there is nothing and no
mention of additional resources for
defense
the defense of this country the defense
of democracy and the defense of the
values and fears of putin's uh
aggression
why is there an options of this today
well mr speaker to the honourable
gentleman you talked about
fiscal windfalls or headroom i'd refer
him to my answer to the honourable
member for the chair of the select
committee uh the headrooms we have are
actually relatively small by historical
standards and could be wiped out very
easily by small changes in the
macroeconomic outlook so i think it's
wrong to say uh there is a huge win for
indeed borrowing for this forthcoming
year will be higher than the proposal or
the forecast was in october uh and with
regard to defence again i'd prefer the
ronald general to my answer earlier to
the um the opposite uh we increased
defense budget by 24 billion pounds in
2020 the largest increase since the cold
war it was the only party the only
department that got a four year
settlement at a time when everyone else
just got a one year that's how seriously
we take the issue you merriman
i'm deputy speaker can i con
congratulate the chancellor for this
statement also in particular the 5p
reduction in fuel duty which i note is
temporary and would he remind all
members of this house that temporary
does not mean permanent and that if it
does become permanent given it costs
five billion we will not be able to
reduce income tax which also costs five
billion if we're also to meet our tests
of fiscal responsibility yeah yeah
i i thank my honourable friend as as
ever for his uh support he's right the
fuel duty cut will benefit all our
constituents particularly those in more
rural areas and on lower incomes he's
also right to make the point mr speaker
madam deputy speaker we do need to
remain disciplined on public spending we
have fully accounted for the income tax
cut and these plans but it will require
a collective discipline to deliver those
tax cuts and others that we want to see
happen over the remainder of this
parliament
alison mcgovern thank you
speaker the government have been warned
privately and publicly not to make it up
when it comes to the employment
statistics so red alarms rang when the
chancellor ex-checker glossed over the
employment numbers in his statement just
now but the small print reveals madam
deputy speaker
that employment
their unemployment
is forecast to rise
next year and then plateau so can i ask
the chancellor exchequer what are the
department for work and pensions playing
at yeah yeah
well madam deputy speaker unemployment
is almost a record low level at the
moment at 3.9 percent uh the forecasts
are all in the obr lower than they were
in their october forecast forecast and
they all are continually still at very
low levels at around 4.2 ish throughout
the forecast period we're very proud of
this government's track record on jobs
record numbers of people on payroll
compared to the forecasts of millions of
people unemployed we've managed to
successfully get everyone back to work
with record number of job vacancies and
we will continue to focus on that
um with the world economy facing
unparalleled challenges from at least
two
of the four horsemen apocalypse death
from plague and war i wonder for all the
challenges facing the chance if anybody
seriously believes that after a decade
of unfunded uh spending promises tax
would be any lower under a labour
government that's a question i think
they should answer but may i make one
question on behalf of pensionable people
of pensionable age
more and more are having to wait a long
time for so-called minor operations up
to two years very debilitating and very
painful
and more more people middle-income
people are dipping into their savings
going into debt to pay for private
operations
will the chance to have an open mind
about giving help to these people with
some sort of tax relief if not on
insurance on the actual cost of the
operation if it's delayed for say up to
two years
well uh madame dave speaker i'm always
happy to take suggestions from my uh
honourable friend um but but also you
know he identifies the pressing problem
that all of our constituents face and
that's waiting longer than we would like
for particularly elective treatment
that's why every penny of our new health
and care levy will go to the nhs and
social care so we can make a start on
that backlog we are backing the nhs to
get those backlogs down and my
honourable friend is right to raise it
sarah olney thank you very much uh madam
deputy speaker um households are facing
the biggest hit to living standards on
record um and they were looking to the
chancellor today to offer them some hope
we also know from the obr forecast that
the treasury will take an additional 13
billion in vat thanks to inflation
so can the chancellor tell us why he
hasn't announced an emergency cut to
that as the liberal democrats have
called for putting 600 pounds back into
the pockets of the average family that's
an unfair tax that puts up prices for
every single family in the uk makes up
half of all the taxes paid by the
poorest households compared to less than
the fifth for the richest thank you
well madame deputy speaker i think it's
wrong to say that there has been a vat
windfall if the honourable lady looks at
the numbers in the ovr forecast you will
see that their projection for vat
receipts for this forthcoming year are
actually lower than their previous
forecast in october but we are helping
working families randomly speak up with
a six billion pound tax cut 330 pounds
in the pockets of 30 million workers
across the united kingdom
robert chen rick thank you speaker well
i think when the chancellor gets back to
his office that portrait of nigel lawson
will be looking down admiringly on him
this is a conservative plan that we can
all get behind it rewards work it gets
the deficit down and it actually
incentivizes investment by businesses
rather than penalizing them with
windfall taxes energy prices as my
writeable friend knows are very volatile
so he's right i think to stand by the 9
billion pound package he brought forward
previously and wait until the next
update on the energy price cap in late
summer if indeed it does show the energy
price are going to rise very
substantially that will have a big
impact on the poorest households will my
writing friend give us an assurance that
he will obviously keep this matter under
review and will consider further
measures if necessary to protect the
poorest
households uh well madame debra speaker
i can reassure my well i thank my
runnable friend for his warm words of
support uh but also reassure him of
course we keep everything under review
as we have stood by the british people
over the past two years we will continue
to stand by them and it's thanks to the
responsible decisions of this government
that we are able to when times call to
provide support that is required
see you in malhotra
madame deputy speaker consumer spending
is vital for the growth of our economy
in the aftermath of the pandemic yet
with inflation nowadays highest level
for 30 years he's seen the data
consumer confidence is declining hitting
our small businesses hard and setting
back their recovery from the pandemic so
why on earth is the chancellor not fully
u-turning on his knicks rise at this
time a rise which the government itself
has admitted will increase inflation and
decrease spending power
uh madam every speaker honourable lady
may not realize that for 70 of people
this is more generous than doing the
thing that c suggests they will pay less
tax as a result of this policy uh as
opposed to the one that she is uh
advocating for so i believe it's the
right policy we're on the side of
hard-working people and this will help
them at a time that they need
stephen hammond
thank you madam deputy speaker and can i
thank the chancellor for his statement
today which has been warmly welcomed by
the people and the businesses of
wimbledon i can tell him and can i
commend him for his analysis of some of
the challenges to the economy one thing
he could make
move from temporary to permanent is the
super deduction and in his consultation
will he look at that because i think
it's already evident that as the most
effective way of changing behavior and
ensuring greater r d in capital
expenditure
oh i thank my honourable friend and i
look forward to discussing these topics
with him over the coming months there's
a range of options outlined for how to
cut taxes on investment in the uh
document today and hopefully he will
have chance to digest that and i look
forward to discussing it further with
him stephen timms
thank you very much speaker
the party opposite introduced universal
credit but instead of upgrading it in
line with current inflation the
chancellor has chosen to increase the
size of the household support fund which
if you've heard of it you have to go to
the local council for what evidence does
he have if any that the household
support fund is effective in delivering
help to those families who need help
most
well madam deputy speaker the feedback i
get from colleagues is that it has been
effective and it and local councils i
trust to know i look i trust local
councils to know in their area who the
people are that most need our help i
used to be local government minister and
as the honourable gentile knows i have
enormous respect and regard for our
local authorities but we didn't just do
that madam deputy speaker in the autumn
budget we cut the tax rate on universal
credit a two billion pound tax cut for
almost two million of those on the
lowest incomes on universal credit
robert halfon um thank you very much
madam deputy speaker um
i just want to thank my uh writing
friends uh heartily for the fuel duty
cut and the and that weighs in the
threshold for the i hope i can retire
from campaigning on this particular
issue
my life my life would be a lot easier
and he has stood up for workers and for
people on low incomes and we should not
forget that as he said it's this party
that is the work of the true workers
party of the united kingdom
could i just ask him on the apprentice
on the apprentice level
on the apprenticeship levy when he looks
at the reform can he make sure that
apprenticeships may remain at the heart
that it focus on getting more
disadvantaged people to do apprentices
young people and people doing degree
apprentices
well um matt bennett
i thank my honourable friend for his uh
support i can't give him that
reassurance apprenticeships are
fantastic we want to make sure they're
continually supported but we will look
at all aspects to make sure that we're
also incentivizing the training that we
we want to see um but he is right then
there's me to highlight that this party
is the party of the workers and that is
in no large part thanks to his
campaigning and i can i congratulate him
on making that case so well
david lyndon
i'm deputy speaker it's quite clear from
looking at the chancellor's statement he
wanted the buzzword to be security
one of the things that wasn't in the
statement was the issue of food
insecurity given that 60 percent of
glaswegians don't have a car many of my
constituents don't own their own home to
put solar panels on it what does he say
to the people whose children will go to
bed hungry tonight and why was there no
mention of that in a statement today
well madame deputy speaker we've already
created the household um sorry the
holiday activity and food program which
provides both food and enriching
activities for children outside of term
time and again with the household
support fund verb consequentials be
available for the scottish government to
provide the same support to vulnerable
families in their communities kevin
holland ray
thank you mr speaker kind of very
give a very warm welcome to his
statement particularly the rising
national national insurance threshold
which uh importantly helps low earners
but also brings welcome simplicity to
the system
in terms of the reforms the
apprenticeship levy which i also welcome
will you look at the amounts that can be
transferred using the annual annual
transfer levy that's currently capped
for larger organizations
who that restricts how much they can
give to smaller organizations a reform
to this would see much better use the
apprenticeship levy which would help
smes local authorities and others
i i thank my uh honourable friend for
his uh support he's right to highlight
that the policy we put in place today
the increased significant increase to
personal tax thresholds is particularly
well targeted for those on lower middle
incomes and i very much look forward to
discussing potential reforms for how we
tax take training and apprenticeships in
this country over the coming months emma
hardy thank you madam deputy speaker
i've just had a message from michael
who's a carer for his disabled wife in
whole and he said so no help for the
disabled i guess i'll have to put my
wife into hospital next winter so she
can stay warm what does a chancellor
want to say to him somebody who doesn't
drive a car and isn't planning on
installing installing solar panels on
his rented home
well madame deputy speaker and obviously
i'm hard to comment on individual
circumstances but in general i'm proud
of this government support for those who
are disabled we spend something like 58
billion pounds on disability welfare
when the oecd do their comparisons uh
madam deputy speaker we rank higher than
many other countries including the us
canada australia new zealand germany and
austria when i last checked the figures
so we are generous and compassionate and
how we support those with disabled
there's a range of things we're doing
not least spending a billion pounds to
help disability people with disabilities
into work providing money one and a half
billion pounds for the disabilities
facility grant to improve the conditions
of their homes and today we announced a
small amount of extra funding madam
deputy speaker for an issue that i care
passionately about and that is improving
the provision of changing places toilets
across the country will increase the
number by 40 percent uh making sure that
the quarter of a million people with
complex disabilities who need access to
those facilities will now find one
closer to where they need it darren
henry
and deputy speaker and i'd like to thank
the chancellor what i thought was an
excellent spring statement and i'll be
looking forward to seeing how this will
benefit my constituents in brockton
particularly pleased to hear about the
cut in fuel duty however a bit
disappointed i didn't hear anything
specific about an increase in funding in
mental health is this something the
chancellor will look at in the future
uh madame bless you i'm happy to tell my
honorable friend uh we announced a
significant increase for the nhs back at
the spending review in the autumn uh the
record nhs spending settlement in claims
big increases for mental health and the
department of health will be able to
provide him with the exact split but i
think he can rest assured we're making
good progress with dedicated funding now
for the cause that he rightly champions
john mcdonnell
can we can we be absolutely clear that
benefits
and pensions are still going to rise by
only 3.1
whilst inflation is predicted to be
between 7 and 10 that's a cut for some
of the poorest in our society but i want
to make this specific appeal to the
chancellor the people i'm desperately
worried about in my constituency are
those who are forced to live